yeah and you teach that I guess I mean a
lot of people like I guess that a lot of
things that I get shared for about yours
or like about meaning and looking into
meaning yes and especially at a time
where it feels like people are
or for me even if I mean it feels like
we're getting into this cul-de-sac in
America where it's like is there a lot
of value to my life do I am I just a cog
in the wheel am I just a consumer is
there any you know what is the purpose
for me I think a lot of people are
starting to ask themselves that yeah
yeah I call that the meaning crisis and
I think there's good evidence that it's
becoming very prevalent in the west
whatever that means these days but you
know sort of North America Europe you
know yeah uh Japan Hawaii yeah Australia
yeah things like that
um and the symptoms are that you can
sort of see symptoms of it
um all through the culture and and I've
also seen a significant increase
um in in the work I'm doing both
academically and in the public sphere uh
especially since covet covet really
ramped a lot of these issues up for
people in a powerful way one of the
interesting things that uh covet did is
it threw people back onto their inner
life
um and what's interesting is our culture
especially North American culture
um right and I'm not the first to
observe it you know it has a high
preponderance of a tendency towards
narcissism being very like you know so
people have oriented their lives in a
very self-centered way but and but they
thought that right or they could maybe a
better way of putting it they confuse
that with having deep rich inner
resources and when everything's sort of
stopped and they couldn't focus the
world on them and they had to focus on
themselves in order to find resources
and what you found was a bifurcation
like a division uh some people were like
whoa that like that really threw them
um so I I I'll I'll say something to you
and I I'm of two two minds of it because
I'm happy about it as a scientist
because I made a prediction and I'm sad
about it as a human being because it's
not a good prediction
um so just as the pandemic was hitting I
said what you're gonna get is you're
going to get a rise in uh turn that
Julian Evans uh made famous called
conspirituality this mixture of
conspiracy theories and spirituality and
that took off and then I said as we come
out of the pandemic we'll get a mental
health Spike and then a little bit later
sort of an increase in crime and all of
these things are coming to pass because
what had happened is many people are
thrown into the interior life only to
realize for all of the
self-centeredness they've actually not
given any wise attention to their inner
life
and they were suddenly without resources
other people saw this as a an
opportunity and they framed it that way
and so what's been springing up where
all of these online communities where
people
not to sound too highfalutin or anything
but people started to say no I really
want to cultivate
wisdom I mean there's tons of
information there's a lot of
mixed up with it there's you know
there's all this stuff and there's
science and that but I want wisdom and
so and I get and I've gotten involved
with quite a few of these communities so
that was that was there's there's both
you still have both negative and
positive symptoms in the culture uh like
you know
um the number of close friends people
have is reliably declining even for all
of our social net internet connections
uh loneliness is becoming
epidemic and loneliness is like it's
very unhealthy we are we are we are
naturally social cultural beings and
loneliness is becoming a hobby too for
some people in a way it's becoming
almost uh so common that it's like um or
not common but it's well I guess common
I guess and once you start to become
something you there's a part of you that
will want to find the most organized way
to be it and to engage in it yeah so
even in loneliness it's almost becoming
a culture you know it is but it's a
culture with great cost
um I mean we we have weird things
happening like the UK has set up a
Ministry of loneliness which sounds like
something out of Orwell right like the
ministry of loneliness yeah and it's
like whoa how did we get there yeah it
sounds like an Ozzy Osbourne album oh
yeah maybe
when it comes to like searching for like
meaning right like as a person you know
do we do it is it something that we do
as individuals like are we do is there
any value in finding meaning as an
individual it feels like to me sometimes
more like the value is finding meaning
as like a species or like a group right
like I guess when I think about meaning
I don't think like
what is my what is the meaning for me
what is the purpose of my life I I find
my brain often thinks more like what is
our purpose right what is our meaning
um do you feel like if that one is more
rewarding than the other or why do we
what's the real value and I don't know
what I'm trying to ask but can you help
me I think I think I do if you'll allow
me to help you yeah please I'll try to
I'll try to be a little bit Socratic
okay okay so
um one way of Perhaps reframing it is
that maybe there's like two polls to
this problem and they're actually
interdependent uh one one half
of the meaning uh issue
um is the fact that and we can get into
the coxai of this the cognitive science
of this is what I this is my cognitive
science but I'll just say it the very
processes that make you adaptively
intelligent like able to solve so many
problems in so many domains in so many
ways those very Pro those very processes
make you perennially prone to
self-deception like they're locked
together I see what you're saying so the
same thing that makes you help you to
figure something out is the same thing
that keeps you in a certain space right
so I won't get into the details of it
right now but like for example the
primary problem
your intelligence is trying well there
are two in any problem you're trying to
solve there are two meta problems I'll
try not to use meta very often but okay
and meta means what like they're they're
they are about they are above uh all the
other problems you have to solve you
have to sort of solve these problems
whenever you're trying to solve any
other problem got it understood okay so
the first is what should you pay
attention to
and that sounds like a trivial because
what you can say is well it's obvious
and here's something and I can back this
up with a lot of argument and evidence
getting a machine to find things obvious
so that it would be a general Problem
Solver is the goal of AGI right so the
fact that you find it obvious doesn't
mean you can explain it in fact the fact
that it is so obvious to you what you
should be paying attention to is the
miracle because think about it Theo
think about all the things you could be
paying attention to in this room right
now think of all the memory and
information you have in the head all the
different ways you could combine them
all the different actions you could
perform you could be lifting an arm
right now right and somehow out of all
of that
you ignore most of that information
and that information is like it's
titanically vast
I give you just let me give you a small
example playing a game of chess
all the different possible Pathways all
the different possible combinations
for playing a game of chess
the number of those Pathways exceeds the
number of atomic particles in the
universe wow that's just for a little
game of chess now look in your
environment all your working all your
long-term memory right and right now my
brain is locked in on the it's it's shut
all that other stuff out that's right to
stay focused on lockdown right here
that's it's pretty remarkable you don't
think about that you just think oh I'm
just locking in on what I'm thinking or
looking at or whatever but really
there's some there's other stuff going
on that's that's stopping all this other
stuff from being like hitting the main
inflection point in my brain that's
right and that's called framing okay
right and so what happens is the it's
you need this this is and the ability to
do this relevance realization I mean you
use realization in both sense become
aware of and make real right this is
like core and that's one of the meta
abilities the other is to anticipate
your your environment you like you in
fact we judge how intelligent a creature
is by how much it can anticipate the
future so for example oh yeah of course
oh yeah yeah yeah right okay good good
okay so you have this in this a patient
problem now the two those two those two
problems are interlocked because think
about it the more into the future I have
to anticipate the more that combat that
explosion of possibilities opens up the
relevance realization issue how do I
what do I pay attention to so you're
just paying attention in this moment if
you also have to like pay attention and
think about what I need to do an hour
from now three hours to tomorrow
Thursday you know
you see how it opens up it'd be very
scary yeah yeah so you are adaptive
right in ignoring the thing that's
making us ignore also sometimes makes us
ignore what turns out to be relevant I
see and it gets even more pronounced as
we're dealing with anticipating the
future this is why getting people to
save for their retirement so this is an
experiment that was done you go in with
you know all the best evidence you go
into academics we we pretend we're the
smartest people and we were supposed to
be responsive to evidence and argument
you give them argument and evidence you
should start saving for your retirement
right now here's all the charts here's
all the graphs you'll allow them to make
any challenges they want that you you
can absolutely convince them they all
agree you come back in six months and
none of them are saving um now here's
what you can do that makes a difference
right you come back and you say you know
what
I want you to imagine don't just think I
want you to imagine your future self as
a as a beloved family member that you've
always taken care of and you feel a
compassionate concern for and I want you
to imagine that as much as you can you
come back in six months and you find two
things
when they're imagining they start to
save and the more vividly they imagine
the more they save right because you
have to you can't just deal with the
truth you have to deal with the salience
how things catch your attention ah I see
what you're saying so you have to not
only have like this idea but if you can
add like weight and girth and
uh make it that idea as Vivid as
possible as it's almost present that's
right like the future is almost you're
able to find a way like a bridge to make
it more present then people are able to
behave
um
maybe in more positive or effective ways
uh in planning for it that's right so I
call that an Ecology of practices all
the practices support each other and
checked and balance and they have
complementary strengths and weaknesses
remember each thing each thing that
makes you adaptive has a dark side and
what you do is you try and pair them so
that they correct for each other's dark
sides right right you get an Ecology of
practices and across cultures and across
time you see people coming up with these
ecologies of practices for overcoming
the self-deception and for increasing
that sense of connectedness and I'll
talk about that in a second if you'd
like right and that's wisdom and so it
so that the individual poll is you need
to cultivate wisdom but what's the
collective pull and you put your finger
on it so what is this meaning thing
so a lot if you do research on it
there's four dimensions to it uh and the
one that people think it's synonymous
with is having a purpose that's only one
of the dimensions it's actually not the
most important one of the dimensions of
meaning yeah meaning in life so we're
not talking about like the meaning of a
sentence we're talking about
what makes your life worth living even
though it has all the frustrations and
failures and faults and flaws in it
right because I think especially you get
to like a middle of your life kind of or
ballpark you know and you start that
really starts to hit home you're like oh
well my youth is disappearing yeah what
is the what is my purpose here and then
is it the purpose of just me or am I
part of a group and we have a purpose
those are the questions yeah that are
really kind of right see us getting hit
with a lot so what happens historically
in a time where we get to a place like
this is there Pat has this happened
before in time okay so we don't need to
be alarmed at the point like humans have
never been through this that's right
we've been through it before uh now
there's a like there's two there's two
uh stances on this that are both sort of
wrong because they're extreme one is oh
this is human beings have always said
the meanings improv and it's a
dismissive thing and then the other one
is no this is completely absolutely
unique and there's truth to both what's
unique is we Face a set of problems that
are Global in a way that was never
Global problems that were this like this
you know complex and and growing like we
Face an interconnection of the Advent of
you know AGI we already we're already
facing you know growing the growing
impact of social media you know people
are looking at issues around the
environment uh energy as you said our
political economic system is breaking
down it's gridlocking and people are
losing faith in it and I use that word
deliberately in in in a deep way and so
those are those are I think unique
things we're facing and they
I think when we're in a meeting crisis
it's sort of
hamstrings us it really weakens our
ability to turn our best wisdom towards
these problems because when we're in a
meaning crisis right so oh especially
enough we're all isolated and we're
isolated and we're not our best it's
very self-motivated it's not our like
group conscience
um we're acting out of fear a lot of
people yeah and we're acting out of like
and our ability to cut through the
and to realize when we're in
self-deception is you know being
seriously challenged oh yeah do you
think we used to get so much more out of
that just in our system because if it
seems like these things that you're
speaking of or things that seem like
Necessities to our soul you know they
are like nothing seems more thirsty
these days than like our soul like
whatever there's like some I almost can
feel this part of underneath me all a
lot of times just
almost like my soul is trying to order
per like
oxycons or something it's like dude what
am I like what am I even doing here
anymore if these are the practices we're
doing a lot of times it's like you can
start to feel it feels bored
you know or did feels like thirsty
that's a better word it doesn't feel
bored it feels thirsty well it yeah
thirsty and but it can vacillate between
profound boredom and extreme anxiety
like so you get the and by the way
thirst that's the that's the the word
that's actually used in the Buddhist
scriptures for what's usually translated
as desire it's more like thirst and
craving it's not a simple desire yeah uh
so yeah and that that craving
um
it's that reciprocal narrowing it's
identifying in a Mindless fact it's all
that stuff we talk about we become
selves through each other and so the
soul is perhaps I mean I'm I'm trying to
rehabilitate these terms so we can
re-inhabit them and there's a connection
between those two words rehabilitate
reinhabit right I'm trying to
rehabilitate the notion of Soul this is
how we right this is our deep
connectedness to our embodiment to our
groundedness our self is our deep
connectedness to each other and our
spirit is our deep connectedness to the
vertical to what is Ultimate and if we
could bring those back so that they can
be simultaneously scientifically
understood
member Socrates and spiritually
transformatively real for us again then
we can do that nourishment you were
talking about and I think it's going to
become it's a necessity I think it is
that's what I think I don't know if that
part of us can die the part of us that
is desperate
for
um
these just like this understanding or
this Comfort or this peace not even like
the comfort of a blanket or of uh but
the comfort of just some connection to
this greater energy that we're supposed
to be yeah like working with